Trascrizione: Carlotta Vielmo
Revisore: Sara Fazzini
Sono un ricercatore
e studio le piante,
e tutto quello che le piante fanno
per noi e per il nostro pianeta.
La nostra vita,
se ci pensate,
dipende
totalmente
dalle piante.
E chi di noi infatti non associa
le piante
alla vita stessa?
Le piante da sempre
ci regalano cibo,
materie prime di ogni tipo,
habitat
per i nostri animali,
paesaggi
spettacolari.
Poi le piante
fanno anche altro e sono importanti
in altri settori,
come quello
della medicina:
la medicina nasce
dalle piante.
E poi, le piante sono molto importanti
anche in campo ingegneristico,
perché trattengono
i versanti, che qui sulle Alpi
sono molto ripidi.
Ma
le piante
fanno
qualcos'altro per noi
di molto,
molto importante.
E a volte noi
non ce ne accorgiamo nemmeno.
Forse perché le piante
lo fanno in modo
silenzioso.
Le piante
mitigano
i cambiamenti climatici.
La temperatura
della superficie terrestre
nell'ultimo secolo
si è alzata di un grado centigrado,
circa,
e continuerà ad aumentare
nei prossimi anni.
I modelli
indicano
scenari veramente preoccupanti,
perché se queste
previsioni
sono corrette
gli aumenti di temperatura
in certe aree del pianeta
causeranno cambiamenti
drammatici,
con forti ripercussioni,
sia a livello locale,
che a livello globale.
Possiamo aspettarci
carestie,
guerre,
emigrazioni
molto intense.
Vedete,
che in alcune parti
del Pianeta
la temperatura si alzerà
fino a 3
gradi
centigradi.
Ma di chi è la colpa
di questo innalzamento della temperatura?
Alcuni ricercatori e modellisti della NASA
hanno cercato di capire
quali sono i fattori
che potrebbero spiegare
questo aumento delle temperature,
dal 1880 ai giorni nostri.
Hanno guardato ad alcuni
fattori naturali come, ad esempio
i cambiamenti
dell'orbita terrestre,
oppure
ad altri fattori,
come, ad esempio
la temperatura del sole.
O altri fattori naturali
ancora,
come le emissioni
dei vulcani.
Ma nessuno
di questi fattori
sembra essere molto importante,
nemmeno se li mettiamo tutti assieme.
Allora
i ricercatori hanno cercato
di investigare
dei fattori umani come, ad esempio
cambiamenti di uso del suolo,
le deforestazioni.
Anche qui
non sembra
qualcosa di importante.
Anche le emissioni di ozono
non sono importanti.
E se invece guardiamo
alle emissioni inquinanti di aerosol,
la temperatura, secondo il modello,
dovrebbe addirittura
scendere.
Ma guardate
i gas serra.
Sono loro
i responsabili
dell'aumento di temperatura.
E se guardiamo tutti i fattori umani
messi assieme,
vedete
come il modello spiega
perfettamente
gli aumenti di temperatura.
Ed infatti,
basandosi su dati come questo,
il 97% dei ricercatori
a livello mondiale
pensa
che i cambiamenti climatici esistano,
siano reali e siano legati
alle nostre emissioni
di gas serra.
E in particolare di un gas serra:
l'anidride carbonica.
Ranga Myneni è un nostro collega,
ricercatore degli Stati Uniti
è stato qui a Trento, al Muse
tre anni fa,
a parlare di scienza
e cambiamenti climatici.
Ha esortato noi ricercatori,
in prima persona,
a fare qualcosa.
A parlare
con la gente,
a cercare di sensibilizzare i portatori
di interesse
o i politici che dovrebbero prendere
le decisioni
per abbattere le emissioni
di anidride carbonica,
cercando strategie di produzione di cibo
e di energia,
sempre più sostenibili.
Ma ci rendiamo conto di cosa significhi
un aumento di temperatura
di 3 gradi centigradi?
A proposito,
c'è qualche sciatore, qua?
Qualcuno a cui piace sciare?
Ecco, ne vedo molti.
Ho brutte notizie per voi.
Non so come dirvelo, cioè
ve lo dico.
Ci sono degli studi austriaci
che dicono che il 60% delle piste da sci
nei prossimi anni sparirà
semplicemente perché
non ci sarà la neve.
A parte gli scherzi,
pensate
all'impatto sulle economie del turismo,
qui sulle Alpi.
E se andiamo un po' più lontano
di queste Alpi
scendiamo nella bassa
pianura padana,
là i modelli dicono che il mare
si alzerà di 2 metri.
E quindi un'area
abitata da un milione di persone
verrà completamente invasa dal mare,
e qui c'è poco da scherzare.
E poi i nostri campi:
l'agricoltura
a causa di questi tre gradi
subirà un colpo molto duro,
ci saranno problemi di siccità,
ma anche da altri eventi
meteorici estremi
che sembrano sempre più frequenti.
E badate bene che le assicurazioni
stanno già vedendo
adesso
i danni
dei cambiamenti climatici,
perché hanno visto un aumento
delle richieste di risarcimento
da parte degli agricoltori
per danni
che quasi sicuramente sono legati
all'aumento di temperatura
e ai cambiamenti climatici.
Ma poi,
in alcune aree del Pianeta,
la situazione sarà veramente
drammatica per l'agricoltura,
la gente sarà costretta a partire,
ci saranno nuovi migranti
e c'è qualcuno
che ha già coniato un nuovo termine
per questi migranti,
che saranno costretti a partire
a causa del clima che cambia:
i rifugiati climatici.
Ma ora vorrei raccontarvi
qualcosa che forse
non conoscete.
La vegetazione,
assieme agli oceani,
sequestra il 50% delle emissioni
di anidride carbonica.
Le trasforma, attraverso il processo
di fotosintesi, in sostanza organica
e poi le conserva, le trattiene,
nel suolo e nel legno,
per decine, centinaia di anni.
E così la sottrae all'atmosfera.
Questo le piante
lo fanno con le foglie,
che sono i loro polmoni.
E questo è il respiro
di campi, prati e boschi.
Questo respiro
non riesce a compensare
le nostre emissioni,
ma ne limita
gli impatti
sul Pianeta.
Io come ricercatore ho un sogno,
e tutti i ricercatori che come me
lavorano in questo campo
hanno lo stesso sogno.
E il sogno è di determinare
le condizioni di equilibrio,
raddrizzare la bilancia:
equilibrio tra emissioni
e sequestro di carbonio,
da parte della vegetazione.
E per ricercare questo equilibrio,
voliamo sulle piante,
le guardiamo dall'alto,
le studiamo.
Da droni,
da aerei,
ma anche dai satelliti.
Cerchiamo di quantificare l'effetto
mitigante della vegetazione
nei confronti degli effetti collaterali
nelle nostre economie.
La prima cosa che facciamo
come ricercatori
è quella di misurare
l'area delle foglie
di tutto il Pianeta.
E a voi sembrerà strano,
ma questa cosa
è relativamente facile da fare.
Quello che è veramente difficile
è studiare la fotosintesi
di tutte queste foglie
a livello globale.
Questa sì che è una cosa difficile
da fare.
Ma anche in questo caso
le piante ci danno un aiutino.
Adesso vi spiego quale.
Le piante sono fluorescenti.
Quando rallentano
il processo della fotosintesi
emettono una debole luce rossa
fluorescente.
La clorofilla che sta nelle foglie
si comporta un po' come le luci di stop
posteriori delle nostre automobili.
Si accende la luce e il messaggio è:
sto rallentando!
E così fanno le foglie,
in questo caso il messaggio è:
attenzione, sto rallentando
la fotosintesi!
E così con queste luci
che si accendono e spengono
noi riusciamo a capire
dove la fotosintesi corre veloce
e dove invece ha rallentato,
dove si ferma.
E se guardate questa foglia
la parte
a destra è scura,
le luci sono spente.
La fotosintesi va avanti veloce,
normalmente.
Ma nella parte sinistra
le luci sono accese,
la fotosintesi ha rallentato.
Questo è successo
perché noi ricercatori
che a volte siamo un po' sadici
con le piante,
facciamo questi esperimenti,
abbiamo spruzzato la pianta
con una sostanza
che blocca la fotosintesi.
E questa luce
noi possiamo vederla
a livello di singola foglia,
a livello di singola pianta,
un bosco intero.
Possiamo vederla
da terra,
vederla in volo
dagli aerei.
Possiamo vederla
perfino dallo spazio.
Ed è per questo motivo che l'agenzia
spaziale europea ha programmato il lancio
di un nuovo satellite che si chiama
Fluorescence Explorer,
l'esploratore della fluorescenza.
Queste
sono le nostre prove di volo,
per la prima volta potremo vedere
la fotosintesi proveniente da tutte
le piante di ogni angolo del Pianeta
e capire qual è l'effetto mitigante
della vegetazione.
Speriamo che questa luce
ci apra gli occhi
sulle reali condizioni di salute
del Pianeta,
e che ci indichi una strada
verso una nuova era
di convivenza e collaborazione
tra noi uomini
e le piante,
per una lunga vita
del Pianeta.
Grazie a tutti.
(Applausi)
Un applauso alla pianta!